but we begin this hour with a powerful
new documentary about the Ukrainian
League of American football and the
impact of the war with Russia on its
players in the new documentary called
who if not us NFL Network's good morning
football host Kyle Brandt Chronicles the
stories of four Ukrainian men from the
league in their Journeys from the
football field to the battlefield here's
a preview of Kyle speaking with football
players Danilo and Yuri
not only our team members but all
ukrainians
understood that we woke up in the new
reality
and we felt a strong internal need to
act so me my brother and Samoa teammates
decided to fight with occupant as
soldiers you didn't have to be a soldier
you could have
done something in the humanitarian sense
you could have hosted a refugee there
were lots of different ways for you to
help the cause
why did you choose to be a soldier why
did you choose to fight our family
wasn't safe but Ukraine not in safe and
many many families
someone need to
to protect our country
[Music]
my close friend and one of the best in
the business Kyle Brandt joins us right
now good morning Carl how are you doing
man it's good to see you it's good to
see all of you thrilled to be here a lot
of memories with this one and I know you
guys are making your own that's right
we'll save those for the commercial
break but um you profile four men in
this documentary how did you find them
and why did you want to tell the story
it's an incredible thing there is this
Ukrainian League of American football
and it's just like our football it's 11
on 11 it's the same positions they
celebrate they score they do the gritty
they do everything we do they love
football
and in February these men woke up to
bombs exploding over their homes and
over their cities they took their wives
and they took their little children and
they fled and they fled for the Border
in most cases either Latvia or Poland
and when they reach the Border they kiss
their wives and they kiss their little
children and they turn right around and
volunteered to the military these were
not soldiers these are businessmen these
are attorneys with no military
experience they had some cursory
training and they took off their
shoulder pads and put on camouflage and
started fighting the Russians and for
eight months I have corresponded with
them much like you would in the olden
days as pen pals I would send them a
video they would send me a video me for
my couch them from in front of a blown
out building and you will not believe
the place The Story Goes this um it's
the most important most powerful and
most painful thing I've ever been
involved with it's amazing what's
amazing about this documentary is it
takes you inside the fox I mean we're we
often see videos from Ukraine from
surveillance cameras and things like
that but it's so up close and personal
and the title who if not us where did
that title come from that's their Creed
that is the translation of a Ukrainian
phrase saying we have to do this this is
the only way we're going to do this no
one else we are outnumbered we are
outmanned we are outgunned and if we
were to stay with our families our
country would be taken over and the
access is unbelievable from the Foxhole
you mentioned there are so many sobering
moments you have with these men I
remember when I was speaking to Yuri who
is the president of the Ukrainian League
of American football and he said I'm a
soldier I'm not afraid of gunfire that's
what I do I'm not afraid of a battle I'm
not afraid of an eye to eye combat what
I'm afraid of is I'm killed in my sleep
by a rocket and I never had a chance to
fight that is some of the things we have
here and you know Nate it's there's
there's a Bedrock of football through it
too and teammates and the lessons
learned and all of those things and
there's levity but it's an unbelievably
sobering thing that I just still can't
believe I was involved with it well you
said something that sort of jumped out
at me Kyle you talked about
corresponding with them from the comfort
of your couch and even as journalists
who are covering this conflict this war
in Ukraine ultimately they get to go
home vast majority of them the men and
women that are fighting this aggression
from Russia have to stay there it is
their home you spoke though to Yuri's
wife they are now refugees living in
Latvia with their uh with her young
daughter their young daughter what did
they tell you about what life is like
there
it's difficult I'm glad you know this I
felt part of the story was I have to do
the best I can to get my hands dirty and
I got to get out of the suburbs and I
got to get out of the cul-de-sac and I
got to get as close as I can I went to
Latvia I went to Poland and that's where
they're living and I met with the wives
and this is me seeing Yuri for the first
time uh in a park in Riga Latvia and to
sit down with these unbelievably
powerful women and hear their messages I
asked one of them I said I'm trying so
hard we all are in the United States to
relate what you might be going through
when you fled in that moment when your
husband said goodbye and you don't know
when you're going to see them or if
you're going to see them do you not
plead with him and say your place is
with us your place is taking care of us
this is this is your responsibility do
you not try to beg him to stay with us
and she said of course not no I would
never my husband is a hero and heroes
fight I would never deprive him of that
and I get goosebumps talking about it
right now I I will never forget it and
that's how powerful those women are
um October 19th was an emotional day for
you Danilo who was one of the players
one of the fighters one of the heroes
was killed in battle and he told you he
said no I don't want to be forgotten
what did he stand for
tinilo stood for everything this cost
stands for there are there are four
gentlemen who I became friends with I
care about these people a lot and this
is after six months of fighting and I
get a message on my phone it's 1 30 p.m
on a Wednesday and I'm doing dishes and
the text was when one of our producers
in NFL 360 that said Danilo has been
killed what's particularly painful about
this is that Danilo was fighting with
his brother this is a video here where
Danilo finds out he was going to be an
uncle for the first time Danilo and
Roman were brothers and not only were
they Brothers they were teammates they
were in the same backfield one was a
fullback one was the tailback they
enlisted together and they decided to
fight separately because they didn't
want their love for each other to be
distracted from their cause
Danilo was in the southern Ukrainian
city of Curson and he was killed when he
left cover to help a comrade and less
than 48 hours I spoke with his brother
Roman as part of this piece and it again
is something I will never forget do his
family members regret him doing this I
know you talked about Yuri's wife saying
she doesn't want to deprive him of
his right to defend his country but I
wonder when you lose somebody do you
then say you know maybe we shouldn't
have gotten involved I thought the same
thing and not for a second yeah they
would change nothing I figured you'd say
that I spoke to Rome and his brother and
I said how do you feel after this same
thing would you have gone back
differently
this man said to me my only fear in this
war the only thing I'm afraid of is
something happening to my brother
and now that my brother's gone I have no
fear there's nothing I'm afraid of and
he has said
now they can't touch me and now I'm even
more powerful and um
very very powerful man I am looking
forward to this thank you for coming and
joining us
um and thank you for your work you know
you have a million jobs you work like I
do you also our husband father coach so
I'm doing an assignment like this I know
it's tough but we appreciate it because
these are the stories we need to hear
when it comes to this fight in Ukraine
Kyle Grant we appreciate you you can see
the NFL 360 documentary who if not us at
8pm tonight on NFL Network